[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause] [Music]
hey guys it's me jasmine and today we're
going to be trying some of blackpink's
favorite foods we got comfort food we
got street food and some other delicious
items as well so let's get started let's
start with this potato hot dog it's a
popular korean street food and is one of
rose's favorite snacks rose is deemed
the foodie of the group and she says
that she especially likes it with some
sugar sprinkled on top which is a
signature topping for korean style hot
dogs we're going to start by making the
batter so in a mixing bowl we're just
going to add our flour
our baking powder
salt
sugar and give it a little whisk let's
make some space here in the middle a
little well and then we're going to add
our egg and milk and just give it a good
mix until we get a smooth batter now
we're going to transfer the batter into
my tall glass i have over here and we're
going to throw it in the fridge to chill
until we're ready to use it now let's
prep our potatoes we're going to dice
them into quarter inch cubes soak them
in cold water for about an hour to
remove the excess starch then we're
going to bring some water to a boil and
blanch the diced potatoes for a few
minutes before rinsing it with cold
water again let's dry them off and
transfer them to a bowl add a couple
tablespoons of flour and toss now let's
set that to the side and prepare our
cheese dogs i have a couple of hot dogs
here we're gonna cut these in half now
grab your mozzarella block and cut it to
match the size of the other half of your
hot dog now i'm gonna skewer my hot dogs
and my cheese blocks i'm using these
wooden chopsticks that i got from take
out now we're just gonna lightly coat
them with some flour we're gonna start
by dipping our cheese dogs into the
batter we made earlier and then coat it
with our diced potatoes making sure we
pack them on nice and tight now we're
gonna cover it with bread crumbs this is
going to make it super crispy and
crunchy now that we have all our hotdogs
prepared we're going to heat up our oil
and place our hot dogs in the pan fry
them for about five to seven minutes or
until they're golden brown top them with
some sugar just like rose loves some
ketchup and it's time to dig in cheers
10 out of 10 would eat this over a
standard corn dog any day it's like a
giant mozzarella stick let's move on to
the next one all right so now we're
going to make lisa's favorite food which
is korean pork neck soup and there are
even restaurants that specifically
specialize in this soup so we're first
going to add in our blanched pork bones
to prep these bones i first soaked them
in cold water for about two hours and
then blanch them for about seven-ish
minutes to rid of the impurities and
that way we can get the cleanest pork
flavor in this soup i'm gonna add in
some more water to make sure all the
bones are covered and now we're gonna
add in one onion three green onions just
the white parts only 10 cloves of garlic
two teaspoons of minced ginger cover it
up and we're going to let this simmer on
medium-low for an hour and a half while
the broth is simmering let's make our
seasoning paste we're going to combine
korean chili flakes soybean paste hot
pepper paste
rice wine
fish sauce perilla seed powder minced
garlic and black pepper to make it a
little easier to mix i'm just going to
add a little bit of water the perilla
seed powder in this seasoning paste is
super important to the dish and gives it
this creamy and nutty flavor awesome the
broth is ready traditionally the
aromatics are removed from the broth but
i don't really want anything going to
waste and also it's just onions and
garlic for the most part which i love so
we're just going to leave them in there
and now we can take our seasoning paste
that we made earlier add it to the broth
and let's give that a good mix and make
sure it is well combined
now i'm gonna add in the potatoes and
once the potatoes are cooked all the way
through we can add in our napa cabbage
leaves our bean sprouts now i'm gonna
add in a few crown daisy leaves these
are part of the daisy family and it has
a crunchy texture and a slightly
mustardy profile and finally we're going
to add in some perilla leaves this is
what a perilla leaf looks like it
belongs to the mint family i find that
perilla leaves can be a bit strong for
me so i'm just going to go with a few
leaves by itself the perilla leaf has a
bit of a licoricey flavor profile but in
the soup it will certainly enhance the
flavor i'm just going to give this a
good mix and we're all set
[Music]
instantly warmed my soul it's so rich
and creamy it's so tender what are you
doing
so good
okay okay there's enough for two of us
you know
no
so in order to make jenny's dish we need
to make jesus dish which is rice and so
to get that signature sticky korean rice
you're going to want to use short grain
rice and not long grain rice though you
will find that all households have their
own preference i came from a short grain
rice household and my boyfriend came
from a long grain rice household and so
now we have both in the house rice is a
huge staple in korean cuisine and it's
honestly the center of most korean meals
it just goes with everything which is
the exact reason why it's jesus favorite
food so when making the rice obviously
you can follow the package instructions
but there is the finger trick which i'll
get to in a second so let's measure out
our rice one cup to be enough for two to
three people and we're just gonna rinse
it in water until it becomes clear this
rice water you can use this water to
wash your skin your hair
water your plants with it it's good
stuff rice cookers will also often come
with guides on the side but they're not
always accurate so the finger trick
comes in handy so let me teach you the
finger trick if you haven't heard of it
before you just want to level out your
rice and so to get the perfect rice
you'll want to add water until it hits
your first knuckle finally we're just
going to grab our rice put it into our
rice cooker
and hit start
she's ready i'm not gonna lie i can
count on my fingers how many times i've
used a pot to cook rice like legit we
really do love rice cookers we'll bring
them camping i could eat like three
bowls of plain rice honestly all right
so jenny's favorite dish is an original
recipe we're gonna use the same rice
from jisu's i'm just gonna reshape it a
little bit
i'm gonna start with the egg yolk so i'm
going to make a little well in the
center right here
drop that yolk in add the pollock roe
then we're going to sprinkle on some
green onions some sesame oil and we're
just going to mix it all up i'm going to
make an avocado rose here i'm gonna peel
the avocado
peel it carefully because sometimes if
you peel it in the wrong angle it'll
lift off the avocado flesh and slice it
very thinly fan it all out and then roll
it up until it's a pretty rose
voila
it does smell really good i can't lie
let's give it a try
that's surprisingly really good
even though the pollock row is on the
saltier side the avocado really helps
balance it out yeah i would say this is
a perfectly balanced dish okay i don't
know which one's my favorite because the
hot dogs are really good and they were
so crunchy on the outside and the sugar
topping was like to die for and then the
pork bone soup was also so hearty yeah
the pork was like melt in your mouth but
this one's really special i feel like
there's a lot of things happening but
also it's very balanced and that umami
flavor in this dish is like
i could eat it every day i can't pick
they're two different you can't compare
them i would pick i'd pick this one
[Laughter]
oh i don't know i can't pick a favorite
they were all really good so you guys
should definitely try them and if you
guys end up making any of these dishes
make sure to snap a picture and tag me
on instagram so i can see bye
oh yes
[Music]
you